historical to suggest that when the
muslims are in charge
that they demonize and ostracize and
alienate
and are unjust towards jewish people
that we will never
accept bernard lewis who is an
orientalist
against against the muslims really he's
an orientalist he even admits
that the kind of catastrophes that we
saw
in europe from the pogroms on the
holocaust
and the spanish inquisition in 1492
there is no equivalent of that in the
muslim world
there is no equivalent in that you know
why because the muslims did have
respect and give it to the jewish people
some people they say what about the
jizya
the jizya under all schools of thor
is even less payment than the zakat but
many people don't know that
what is the discriminatory tax you're
talking about
it's not a discriminatory tax when it's
less than the tax that the muslims have
to pay
and so these fallacies and misnomers and
misconceptions
about muslim jewish living is false
and we say in fact the of the two
abrahamic religions that are probably
most close to one another
in terms of theology especially as it
relates to god
islam and judaism are very very close
we believe in moses we believe in dawood
david
we believe in solomon we believe in all
of those prophets we believe in all of
them
and we respect them and we love them and
in fact we cannot even be muslims
without them
and so therefore there shouldn't be this
kind of friction between
jewish people and zionists and sorry
jewish people and muslims let me tell
you something
some of these individuals say the
following they say muslims keep it
closer bro
some people say yes some people say that
muslims are anti-semitic
and i say to them how is it possible
that muslims can be anti-semitic
when one of the wives of the prophet
sophia
was a jew she was jewish from a jewish
lineage of aaron
there's no doubt about that and in fact
in one occasion
she was being abused by some of the
other wives of the prophet
because of her jewishness and the
prophet stuck up for her
telling her to reference her lineage as
a point
of honor tell them that your
uncle is aaron who is a prophet
he said anti-semitism is impossible
for muslims because to be anti-semitic
we would have to attack one of our
mothers the mothers of the believers
who is in fact more than this they'd had
to attack one of our prophets
who is moses how can you be anti-semitic
how could you not like
how could you hate jewish people based
on their jewishness
based on their ethnicity how can you do
that
when our prophets came from a jewish
lineage
it's not possible remember judaism is an
ethno-religious
construct it's an ethnicity as well as a
religion
so we say this we say the attempts of
the mainstream media
and the propagandist the zionist
propagandist to try and conflate
zionism with anti-semitism
is only dangerous for them because you
are opening the door
to more serious crimes of anti-semitic
feminism to be open
and you're not going to be able to close
that door it reminds me
when you make a mockery out of rape and
you say rape is and you define it in
such a ridiculous way
any kind of sexual thing then when the
real rape
happens then you are trivializing the
pride of the rape
the victim same thing here when the real
anti-semitism happens
you will be trivializing the plight of
the jewish people in their communities
who are in fact
being attacked as a result of their
ethnicity
and because of what religion they decide
to follow
when you say that anti-semitism is
equivalent to
or anti-israelism anti-zionism is
equivalent to anti-semitism
we cannot accept that discourse and in
fact doing so
will alienate the voices of people like
this behind me
brave and gallant people brave and
gallant people that have stood up for
truth
one of the things that one of the rabbis
said
one of the rabbis said he said that very
interestingly is his perspective and his
interpretation of the torah
he said that we are in an exile he said
and us trying to establish the state in
we are trying to defy the exile of god
and what's really interesting is that
there is a verse in the quran
there is actually a verse in the quran
to that effect now some people say
this is referring to the state of israel
he says
if you do good then that will be for
yourself and if you do bad
then that will be for it but when the
second time comes
and this is very interesting when they
come
into the masjid and what is it referring
to here
masjid al-aqsa when they come into the
message for the second time
and those who are arrogant there will be
humiliated
and they will go into the masjid and
they will destroy
that which has happened before some
scholars say this
is talking about the present state of
israel and that there will be a conquest
whether they like it or not and that is
the promise of allah
now some will say well we don't know if
that's what he's talking about but there
is a hadith
that the last on the last days there
will be people
who will be literally on the periphery
of the jerusalem mosque
and that they will be at pakistan the
true
sect we talk about sector in islam
like divisions and groups and whatever
there's only one one
to sect and they will be the ones who
will eventually liberate
from the occupation and this is the
reality of the situation
so we are aligned in those meetings and
on those interpretations
and we say today to our jewish visitors
and
our jewish friends companions
that we truly respect what you are doing
you truly are a great representation
of justice and truth and now
by doing what you're doing i promise you
when our
youth walk in the streets and see you
in in your attire they won't be thinking
these are the people that attack
and celebrate the deaths of our children
they will they will think twice before
that happens and they'll think to
themselves
actually these guys could be very well
the ones who supported us in our time of
need
they will be thinking these are the ones
who support
the palestinians who condemn the killing
of 66 innocent people
by the brutal regime
and that believe me is better than any
propaganda that any zionists can do
so what i want to say is this
but i want to say one more thing ladies
and gentlemen
today i was meant to have a discussion
with you a quick talk
and what i wanted to say to you is this
there is a hadith
because the question is why is this
happening
why is this happening to us why is it
that this is happening in palestine and
so on the prophet saws
he predicted this he told us
where the nations are going to
split you apart just like when you're in
dinner time and you're splitting apart
your food
subhanallah you know when you're having
dinner you eat biryani i don't know you
have curry you have this you have that
papadum roti whatever you have
and you say to your friend give me the
roti you say to them give me that i
don't know what
the papa's done and you you mixing it
about like this
the prophet told us that basically this
is the way
that the nations are going to be
splitting the muslims up
just like this so one of the sahaba
illustrated
he said rather on that day
that you will be kahir you will be a lot
be a lot in number
however you will be like the scum
the rubbish meaning you don't have much
quality in you
you'll be scummish you'll be rubbish
is silly just like when you go to the
sea and you see the foam on top
like the scum on top of the water
on the torrents are taking it away the
prophet told us this
so the the sahabah were interested they
say why is that the case
and the prophet also said well i am
[Applause]
away from the hearts of your enemies
this is very important not only fear but
respect
that they will lose fear and respect for
you muslims your enemies
they will lose fear and respect for you
and then he said something else
he said that that you will have in your
hearts
he asked the sahaba said what is
that when you love the dunya and you
hear you fear death
this is the hadith the hadith
is this we as the muslim community now
despite our numbers despite the fact
that we are lots in number
unfortunately we have not been able
to punch at our weight we have
fulfilled letter by letter line by line
word by word the hadith of the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi
that prophecy of the future exactly
happened
how do we get out of this the question
now is
what is the solution now we've already
done the prognosis
what's the solution the solution is this
very carefully listen carefully
number two what number one sorry the
prophet said that the
enemy will be dividing us right divide
and conquer
and it's as if he was there when uh mark
sykes
and kiko were literally in in the early
1900s dividing the countries and
if you look at the map there's why is
that why is there like straight lines on
the map
because the colonizer literally put a
ruler to the pen and said this is going
to be egypt
like that so it's why why is it like a
like a block
this is going to be you know this
country's they did it like that
this so the first thing is about unity
it's very important
in indeed those people who divided their
religion
and shia became different sects and now
we actually have a sect called that
funny enough
then you've got nothing to do with them
this is what allah said to the prophet
muhammad
you have nothing to do with them anyone
and listen carefully young people
anyone after you become practicing in
the religion of islam who tells you look
this is the only right way this is the
only
this shaykh is the only shaykh that is
going to bring you to jannah
this will like if anybody tells you that
from any side in the spectrum
salafi and they are falling into this
dividing and conquer technique that's
been happening from the beginning of the
20th century
they came to our country
they came to our countries literally
lawrence of arabia
came into the arabic lands and he told
them look why are you
why are you being governed why are you
being governed by turkish people
and he put in their hearts
he put in their hearts this love for
nationalism
and patriotism and they put above their
islamic identity their national identity
and as a result of it
the ottoman empire was basically the
beginning of the end for it
so dividing and conquering has been an
ancient tactic
and ancient these people have been doing
some of the brothers help them hold the
signs please can you go and jump in with
them please help them
let's have a nice mix of muslims and our
fellow jewish friends
yes
say unity unity yes upon the right
principle
but that is number one because the
prophet told us there will come a time
where you'll be divided
meaning in order to rectify this
situation we will have to be united
that's the reality the second thing is
this he said that you will be
that you will be basically like the
torrent the rubbish the scum of the
of the water of the sea so what we have
to do now
in order to get the mahiba back from the
from those enemies what we have to do is
we have to build ourselves up
in every single way possible i say that
honestly
now it's the time for all of our youth
to think about
not just contributing for themselves the
individualistic idea of i'm doing it for
myself i want to get married when i have
a kid like this and that and then die no
now whatever you choose to do in life
whether it's to go to medical school
whether it's to be an engineer whether
it's to do this or to do that
now you have to have a dual purpose in
mind i i want to do it for myself
but b how am i going to make this
contribute to the ummah
how am i going to make this contribute
to the muslim community
and muslim muslim
i say this to you we must start
rebuilding ourselves
individually as families as communities
and then internationally
that is the only way forward we want to
see islam implemented let's get it
implemented in our own homes
in our own backyards we need this now
more than ever before because there will
come a time
where the victory as allah says will
come to us the victory will come
it's not about a matter of if it's a
battle of wind
but the question is the boat is gonna
come and go are you gonna go onto the
boat
meaning are you gonna start thinking in
alignment with the
objectives of the of the community the
muslim community are you not
now that's what i say to you the muslims
now we have to start thinking
about the community anything you choose
to do think about one question
how can what i do contribute to the
ummah
i'm not giving you any specific or
precise answers you find figures out
yourself
you want to be a doctor if you want to
be an engineer whatever you want to do
the question you have to have in your
mind now how is what i do
gonna contribute to the ummah believe me
the people in palestine have been
already promised victory
they have been promised that don't worry
too much about them
he says in the quran and this will be
the last thing yes that i say
[Music]
m
allah
of those people that are attacking us
don't let that grieve you
that certainly to allah belongs all of
the might
so allah belongs all of the might
all-knowing so these people who have
been killed and made shaheed
we should not be too sad about this
because they are now in sha allah
in jannah
we should be feeling sorry for ourselves
because we are here
being tested with being good believers
in this kind by the way the same thing
i'm sure applies you know the struggle
in a society like this and we have to
remain steadfast
and and really the hisab on us is going
to be much more than on them
allah has honored them to put them in
that place and make them the center of
the struggle in the ummah
and we what we can do is
do everything in our humanly power and
possibility
to give them nothing victory and to give
ourselves nothing
wassalamualaikum warahmatullahi
foreign